no strangeness I don't think I've ever
seen anything like that and instead he
opens with his Kings Born and we have a
French defense on the board
yes so another thing we have seen from
Magnus earlier in the tour finals he
used this to defeat Anish giri as black
and will we see lightning strike twice
okay Prague didn't go for the move that
giri went for expanding forward in the
center instead he brings his Bishop out
a Magnus plays a really old move
very rare move he sacrifices important
so we saw Bishop for night trade and if
white wanted if Prague wanted to he
could have captured Black's Pawn in the
center
and there wouldn't have been direct
consequences there you could get away
with that but black maybe would have
gained a bit of time instead taking a
timeout and pushing A3 I must admit I've
never seen this position before
um I've seen the position up until one
move back but this is really rare
already and Prague is playing instantly
not surprised at all despite the fact
that Magnus
surely he kind of played this look at
him retreating his Queen now he's
definitely putting on a show he's not
obeying the opening rules what is three
Tempe ahead in development whites minor
pieces are all out black is faster
homeless sleep asleep all of his pieces
I think this is part of his anti-youth
strategy where he plays very strange
provocative chess says to his opponent
hey come get me but ultimately Magnus
does have a solid foundation I mean take
a look at that triangle horns it is okay
that is very flexible and Magnus does
have the bishop pair the problem is is
that his position is very very cramped I
would not recommend that you'd play this
at all I mean I think it's it's only for
specialized Grand Masters to play this
way not for the average Joe yeah I might
play like this in Blitz but not against
someone as strong as Prague and
definitely not in Rapid chess where with
15 minutes Prague also with a
development Advantage it feels like he's
got everything he dreamed of in a
must-win situation White's Queen is
going to step forward whites of Rooks
are going to centralize and the pressure
is all on black
how is Magnus really going to alleviate
the pressure look at Black's light
squared Bishop as well how is that ever
going to get in the game
I yeah I'm surprised I must admit that
the evaluation bar is not impressed at
all I've got to go and research uh go
and go and study my openings because I'm
learning something new in this one yeah
yeah and the Santa is going to be so
dangerous that I I would be just like so
eager to relieve attention and trade if
trade a set of Pawns in the middle
but that this is my style because
otherwise I just don't see what black is
doing yeah would you get tempted to
Castle now it looks like black needs to
castle at some point but Black's King as
soon as it commits might come under some
attack yeah I I wouldn't necessarily be
tempted to Castle just because why it's
Bishop on D3 is on the perfect attacking
diagonal and I would be very nervous of
that
yeah so White's Bishop well placed
whites Knights ready to hop forward if
uh if allowed somehow Magnus again
Taking Liberties pushing a pawn he's not
afraid as long as he closes the center
this is just the theme we've seen
throughout the season it's just modern
chess and it's Magnus being provocative
leaving his King in the middle
as long as possible just while the
center is blocked while there are no
open lines but now the white Rooks are
going to line up against that black king
one of the Rooks will occupy the e-file
and how much longer can he continue to
uh push the boat out like this
I mean I'm half impressed I'm half just
shocked by what's happening
uh it does feel like this is an advert
for what not to do in the opening of
black but Magnus is getting away with it
timing again every single game yeah
[Laughter]
the bad news and it takes a certain
level of Mastery to play cramped
positions I guess but I mean this is
magnus's sense of humor I mean I have
seen on like
um some streams that Magnus has done
like that he just gives his opponent
literally eight moves in a row and then
goes and beats them you know
some people can do that some people
can't most actually I should say most
people can't and Magnus developing his
light squared Bishop but it's looking at
a wall of Pawns but still those wall of
Pawns that black has means the position
is incredibly solid it's going to be
very difficult for Prague to break it
down
yeah and that strategy you mentioned
just giving your opponent loads of free
moves uh recently when I was writing a
an article just in memory of Mike
Bassman who passed away I was looking at
this Immortal waiting game or that was
the term used for it and I think he gave
his opponent was it 12 moves for free he
just waited he moved his Bishop back and
forth then he moved his King back and
forth 12 moves he gave a world-class
opponent and then he went on to win so
sometimes that's a strategy you kind of
lure your opponent forward then they
leave weaknesses behind a new
counter-attack
maybe that's one of these situations
he's just going to say to Prague you
advance you push you commit and I'll
react no matter what you do
I have to say I did see that game
played by elf Anderson against Mike
Bassman and what made me giggle a lot
was the comments on Twitter After People
posted that link The Immortal awaiting
it though why did you make me waste my
time looking at one side just shuffling
the pieces backwards and forwards and
literally was like the king moved to the
H7 on G8 yeah yeah it just went there
about 10 times I mean it was incredible
it's a viable strategy if the center is
blocked and that is the situation right
now between Prague and Carlson so
practice centralizing all of those
pieces this is essentially what we teach
in kindergarten in chess just put your
Knights on F3 and ce3 put your Rooks on
E1 and D1 put the White Queen out put
the white Bishop on this Square this is
exactly what we teach youngsters when
they're new to the game but the question
is what next and that's what Magnus is
trying to ask I think we will see black
Castle now surely or maybe the black
queen will move is there time for that
luxury and then it's up to Prague to
come up with a plan a productive plan
yeah White's already got the ideal setup
is what comes next yeah I agree with you
I do think the queen will move I think
we're going to see some other waiting
move another Shuffle yeah it goes on
exactly because I think Magnus is just
determined just to put the ball in
practice courts and say you take the
decisive measure if I Castle then it's
very easy for white to come up with a
plan if uh there you go why Castle why
commit it's only move 12 move 13 and now
Magnus he's hinting that he might Castle
even on the queen side on that left side
and remember he castled on moved what
was it 22 in the previous game in one of
the previous games today
he still wants to delay that as long as
possible
and it is up to Prague how does he get
his Knights into the game it's not 100
clear I've got to give Magnus credit for
that it's not clear what Prague should
be doing here
it's uh roughly to the middle but in
game three between Duda and so the bar
is already way up for Wesley Seoul and
look at Duda oh he's frustrated already
he has to win this game otherwise he
will lose the match and let's hear what
Wesley Seoul said after winning game two
Wesley you're leading the match with two
game wins you look like you're having a
lot of fun on the board today
yeah for sure I mean I have a lot of a
lot of respect for young Kristoff it's a
very strong very young player I have
played quite a number of games with him
he's a Polish number one and uh he's a
very resourceful very tactical third
thing I first played them in 2015. in
the French league when he was by the
teenager I think he was playing board
one for some team and we played the
brayer and he defended very strongly and
after that I since had another first
pack for him
and as usual with a two game point lead
uh strategy for game three would be yeah
play play further I mean
I think the first game went very
smoothly I think Jan is not the best
theoretition like compared to Anish gear
for example but he's
like seems to be plays more for the
middle game and I think eight during the
first game of an unfortunate move
because I look briefly and after the
game after eight or blacks just slightly
better so I had absolutely no problems
in the opening and I mean he probably
could have made the door on the first
game but he got a bit too aggressive
and uh the second game went out of my
control I mixed up the opening like this
latex C4 line is not very common betting
after Queen B1 B6 I think Knight G5 is
probably a mistake I should just play
like Bishop E2 Castle short and enjoy uh
pretty decent position I think yeah
after it wouldn't be gonna be fixed
because in the game it got a bit out of
control like I couldn't regain my pawn
and I obviously had very good
compensation but I also had no idea what
to do because I had maybe three
different plans and then I decided to go
for the most aggressive plan with my H4
and E5 but he's got a lot of points and
I suspect that Black's got to be better
at some point
like I didn't want to take the exchange
um but then I decided I just have to
grab some material someone played Queen
before Queen fit two B5 black was taking
over like I was quite unhappy with my
position but I was very
happy to find this move broken E1
because attacking point isn't because I
realized I just have to try and mate him
otherwise he's gonna promote his Queen
side Pawns
uh when you play Queen bitter maybe I
should just trade queens and try to make
a door with rookie three but I wasn't
sure if it was a clear draw
from play Quincy one night G6 Rook E6 I
think King F7 was just a blunder using a
point so I should play C5 and then I I
don't know if black is better or
whatever but it's amazing to see you
play out all the variations right after
the game so even after winning uh what
has just happened still goes on in the
mind yeah for sure I think the second
game was very very interesting uh I mean
I think Jan had pretty good chances and
he didn't need to lose but but now we're
not too seriously I mean it's you should
you know unless I really mess it up
somewhere I mean those here is such a
big lean a four game match it is a big
lead game three coming up we'll see you
back on the screen thanks Wesley
and while that interview was uh going uh
that was recorded of course before this
round going on the bar has gone slightly
down for Wesley so but he only needs a
draw in game three to win the match
against Duda raising his eyebrows there
and it's dude at tilting a massive tilt
here from Duda he looks like he just
wants the day to be done yeah he wants
it to be over and actually in that game
Wesley had a winning Advantage as black
after eight moves and uh Wesley he's
played it slightly safer over the last
few turns which is understandable only
needing a draw but Duda not enjoying
life right now and I think we've all had
this feeling at some point in our chess
careers sometimes things just go against
you your opponent's playing great you're
blundering and
yeah that's life apparently he's been
sitting like this for three minutes dude
he lost the match yesterday and uh
against Prague today it's not looking
good for him and tomorrow he faces
Magnus Carlsen on the final day of the
tour finals pranked on Allah he is also
in a must win situation here in game
three against Magnus and it's anything
special happening with the last few
moves well position has clarified since
we last talked about it we said the
center was very blocked and instead of
blocking it even further Prague did
trade off one set of Pawns and now he's
kind of gone straight for the black king
but in a weird way he's planted his
Knight on H5 that white knight looks
very strong on the edge of the board
very close to delivering some checks
maybe even sacrificing itself but this
last move by Prague he's really
desperately trying to eliminate Black's
Knight which could be a Defender yeah
what do you think of this uh Ivanka he's
aiming for two nights against two
Bishops yeah I thought he was aiming for
checkmates actually I I thought that
Prague is paying in a very desperate
direct style so with the idea of off the
bishop takes Knight the Knight will then
come to F6 and then the queen will find
herself all the way on H6 and maybe
there's a nasty attack Brewing once
Queen would jump out and Black's King
actually it's suffocated by its own
Rooks it wants some
squares simply to run over with it wants
to run away but it can't because the
Rooks are in its own path and white will
add the Knight add the Rooks to the
attack shortly this does look very
dangerous so Magnus decides you can't
allow this and uh of course that would
have been initiated by white taking this
Knight so Magnus blocks the tension here
and instead it's the Bishops that
disappear I'm very surprised by this
I've got to admit because if you just
Retreat if we go back a few moves what
is Black's Bishop doing this is the
worst piece on the board by a mile and
Prague has just said yeah I'm going to
swap you off I'm going to trade you off
for my great Bishop on this diagonal to
me it makes zero strategic sense but
these must have some dynamic
ideas in mind he trades office Bishops
and now he goes up with his Rook yeah I
agree with you there David I mean I
would never have traded off that Bishop
I mean I I really do like to attack but
also to have a good strategy and a
strategical advantage and uh here Magnus
well he's very good isn't he he swings
his Rook to the open line and attacks
the pawn so now Prague has to take a
time out has to push his C Pawn one
square foot and then again Magnus now
has a chance to untangle a little bit
more on the king side yeah Magnus gets
chance if he wants maybe to push his
Pawn forward to kick away the White
Knight or he can just continue and start
playing on this side of the board this
is what we call a minority attack I'm
not sure whether he'll go for this
immediately but these two pawns will
undermine these three so two versus
three and either way white will be left
with an isolated pawn and a long-term
Target it's still trying to attack but
he might not get opportunity Magnus is
starting to kick him back okay oh
important game if Magnus gets a draw he
will win the Tour of finals he is
playing in San Francisco and Tanya is
not the only chess celebrity in San
Francisco Maurice Ashley is in the house
Tanya
he is in the house he's the resident
Grand Master for the day and of course
we just can't get enough of the chess
action that's going on inside the
playing Arena we've got the puzzle set
up which is the puzzle of the day for
the viewers Maurice don't look just yet
now for those of you who don't know
Maurice is not just a grand master but
he also creates puzzles so it's going to
be interesting and fun to watch how he
approaches this one this one's for our
viewers and and players for the day
Maurice it's super tough uh just a heads
up David said it's one of the toughest
mate in twos
um all the best I'm gonna start your
time uh take us through how you approach
this position good luck it's not good
when David houses this is one of the
toughest made in twos but I do solve a
lot of puzzles I do create a lot of
puzzles myself made in twos without even
looking at the puzzle they have one
fundamental secret and that fundamental
secret is that it either your move must
either threaten mate or it has to be
looks wrong that's it so whenever you
look at a puzzle that's the deal so
looking at this it looks very clean a
lot of times these puzzles are messy
but my eye immediately goes to the h8
square like if I could play Queen h8 and
mate somehow that looks like it should
be the solution so I want to play
uh I want to play Queen A8
uh and if you play King takes I have
Queen takes D5 that looks that looks
really good uh the Knight moves away
Queen D5 is also but wait there's Knight
of Knight F6 28 Knight F6 is um
45 seconds 906 is a problem I don't see
a mate I don't I don't also even with my
queen a why isn't this Rook on age six
working The Rook usually kind of yeah
you know usually have any kind of
Superfluous pieces in The Rook The Rook
doesn't make sense on the H6 Square I'm
not really
I'm not really sure why it's sitting
there it coming Brook cage forward these
look like ugly moves to play
Queen E1 is also a problem I have to
have a response to Queenie it looks so
perfect 75 seconds is that you're on so
Maurice do you want to go with Queen no
no no no no hold on hold on wait a
second Queen f one queen of one oh
that's beaut that's nice that's actually
quite nice Queen F1 because after Queen
F1 the move that you have to worry about
is King takes but there's this beautiful
move Queen F5 the bishop is pinning The
Rook on D5 The Rook is pinning the queen
and now the Rook on H6 is in play it's
pinning the pawn on G6 Queen F1 that's
the kind of movie you want to play that
is sexy as ever Queen F1 yeah I don't
see Queen takes Rook I can take it's
mate the Knight can't move because the
queen have six
The Rook C5 is Queen F4 that's ball game
wait it is queen of one it's got to be
that's what you make a puzzle for this
is satisfying listen yeah this one is
beautiful queen F1 is crushing with the
queen with three mates F4 F5 and F6 you
can't beat that that's uh that's nasty
wow okay David we
Maurice is coming
Maurice is the man he's got it Queen F1
and queen F5 especially
you do it awesome
is beautiful that's a puzzle oh that's
fantastic I love that segment and
Maurice Ashley is such a legendary
Grandmaster he's really praising your
puzzle David yeah but I've got to praise
Maurice he's put out a great course on
chessboard recently about chest geometry
so I had no doubt he would solve this
the geometry in this puzzle was the key
and also shout out to Maurice because I
grew up watching his commentary I
remember my first VHS tape was him
commentating with Danny King on a on a
game I think in 1994 so uh yeah one of
my favorite players commentators great
person fantastic and even that's not
often you hear in the chess it's a sexy
answer to this puzzle I like that that's
nasty and I also have to say a big
congratulations to everyone on Twitter
who has has there been the answer yes I
mean it's it's really lovely to see that
first of all as the minutes tick in
people weren't getting it and then as
the time kind of started going people
started working it out and they were
like yes it's Queen F1 with this
beautiful queen of F5 check a lot you
know it's it's very rare that you allow
a check and then you deliver a Checkmate
yeah that's so unheard of but also a big
shout out to the composer
1877
Charles Alexander Ginsburg man wow just
to have the creativity to compose that
and uh basically I'm also going to shout
out to all the chess composers out there
as well you know you guys are just
entertaining us chess players on a
regular basis and would this be a good
moment to show the answer maybe so the
players that they're just maneuvering at
the moment nothing too dramatic
happening on the board we will update
you guys with the developments of Prague
against Carlson but uh maybe now is the
right moment to show what Maurice had
solved this was the meeting two that we
gave everyone on well done to everyone
for trying but as Marie showed it's
actually very difficult to trap this
King in the center of the board the only
way to made it in two moves is to
retreat the White Queen this is so
counterintuitive to bring it back the
whole way
firstly you protect your Rook so Black's
Queen for example if it takes this Rook
now this would end in Checkmate there's
nowhere for the king to run uh the Black
Knight if it had moved would allow the
White Queen to come up to F6 this is
another thing that Maurice mentioned
there's a mate on F6 in this scenario
the king is trapped and the key the most
beautiful Checkmate is here black can
actually take a knight with check
hitting the white king but you block a
check with a Checkmate this never ever
happens but you drop your queen on F5
and this is Checkmate it's a triple pin
the black Rook can't take the White
Queen because it is pinned along this
diagonal The Black Queen can't take the
White Queen because of a pin along this
line and the black porn cannot take the
White Queen because of a pin along the
sixth rank so this is just a beautiful
finish and something you'll very very
rarely see well done to Maurice and all
of those at home who solved it that is
chess art that is just beautiful and
super difficult so shout out to everyone
who was able to figure it out and I and
we hope you enjoyed it sitting trying to
solve it even if you were able to even
Grandmasters struggle with that one
and then this one I know you showed it
to Magnus once as well did he solve it I
think yes he did solve it but I think it
took him about the same time as Maurice
so it's really instructive Maurice he's
very experienced at problem solving and
you know the way to think we saw his
thought process there he's looking at
various moves but then he sees defensive
resources and it's the same in chess you
see your opponent's ideas you see yours
and it's just putting them in the right
order making them all fit together
nicely so Magnus solved it the quickest
player I've ever seen solve it was Anish
Gary we sold it in maybe 30 seconds
maybe even less so that's very
impressive yeah but he solved it too
quickly I think that he'd seen it before
oh maybe a niche
and uh meanwhile this game is heating up
slightly uh we have had a few
developments since we last uh discussed
the position let's jump in to show what
has happened Magnus now is pushing pawns
on that left side but we left it here
and uh we said that the White Knight was
very strong it's a potentially uh
powerful attacker so Magnus tried to
kick it back and actually this Knight
had no good Retreat squares if the
Knight steps back immediately then black
creates a pin now you pin and you win
you win material here the white Rook is
doomed so instead Prague had to be
really creative in order to save his
Knight he stepped back with his rook and
now actually the Knight might be
poisoned if you take it you allow the
White Queen to swoop in and the black
king now in Mortal danger so Magnus
decided in a situation where he just
wants to draw this was too risky he
moved his King across to defend the H6
Pawn this was another pin that
practically reinstated and uh suddenly
we saw a porn move the Knight jumping in
getting traded off and uh now yes Prague
is trying to swing his right across but
there's no clear way in towards the
black king therefore Magnus decided
there's time to Simply push pawns and
again to push once more and we do see
this minority attack now this one Pawn
is undermining two pawns and uh White
will be left with a weakness on this
side that's guaranteed now white will be
left with an isolated Pawn long term
black is doing very very well Prague has
to deliver Checkmate otherwise he's
going to crash to another defeat in this
game
you have to go for the black king
somehow it's not easy however and that's
why he steps up with his uh Rook one
square in order to defend the weak point
on C3 and I agree with you you know look
the computer says it's better for black
but
two humans playing Magnus still very
much on the defensive if he makes one
wrong move that's it pregnant under his
attack will just crash through yep
Craig's idea I think is to swing one of
his Rooks across maybe even both Rooks
across and to try and break through on
this G6 Square to try and sacrifice here
um you know the White Queen is on a
great diagonal in terms of attacking so
she's doing a multi-purpose job she's
holding some pawns together she's eyeing
up the black king and uh yeah Magnus
still has a couple of accurate moves to
find in order to kind of cement his
Advantage if he takes the time out and
just moves a rook for example then
already it gets very scary uh you're
right about this Ivanka if you move the
Rook again for example just to
illustrate the point suddenly the white
Rook shuffles across and there's the
threat of a breakthrough Rook sacrifice
on this Square again just to show this
suddenly the White Queen could swoop in
Queen takes porn delivering Checkmate
and winning this Rook as well yeah this
is actually very very scary to deal with
my Darkness however goes very direct and
he tries to skewer these Rooks
he allows the white knight in though I
was going to say that you know
immediately I would just put that Knight
on F6 give a check to the king and let
the rest
work itself out so the king will move I
probably will step to the G7 Square as
you've highlighted and okay where's the
way to put pressure on the black
position yeah I worry for Prague because
maybe White's best is to actually repeat
the position white for example could
jump back with a knight hoping that the
Knight is captured because suddenly
lines would open up towards the black
king this is not what Magnus wants but
the problem for Prague is after the
Knight drops back you don't have to take
it you can just sidestep again and we
might see a dance between the knight and
king a check a side step a check a side
step and the game might be a draw if you
don't go for this maybe you're just
losing his Prague because remember there
is this skewer of the Rooks yeah but uh
a lot a drawer is the same as loss so
that option you just cannot play it you
just have to do something else I mean is
there anything else I mean for instance
move the Rook on I know that's the
problem can you
move it across and move it across and
after Bishop takes work
just one move too slow for example okay
I was going to say he could try stepping
this Pawn forward trying to break
through with the sacrifice here but
Black's Bishop is just in time to come
back and block yeah and okay he's going
for that immediately prag he's pushed
his Pawn forward but what is happening
here Bishop takes Rook looks like an
automatic it does look like an automatic
and I'm guessing that The Rook will then
slide over to the G3 square and there is
some pressure on the G6 Pawn but again
it feels like it's too slow after Bishop
takes porn is that possible yeah Bishop
takes Pawn Rook takes and suddenly this
is ending in Checkmate because uh the
White Queen does jump in just in time to
support her Knight and look at this a
kiss of death
trapped in the corner
so there is still significant danger in
the position
Prague okay yes it's not working
according to a computer but he's setting
some very difficult traps here for a
human to navigate Magnus does take the
Rook but how is he going to deal with
this mating attack once The Rook slides
over
Rook takes Pawn is devastating if it
happens yeah
yeah okay the evaluation Bar says black
is still in charge
how narrow is the path though preg has
to slide over with his Rook what is he
thinking about he's a whole Rook down
and this is the current position and you
cannot take this bishop you cannot take
this piece because you are pinned along
the C file
so you just have to move over what is he
even thinking about here Prague well
he's probably considering whether he can
play Pawn takes Pawn is that is that
something I mean I'm just looking at the
checks and the captures so Pawn takes
pawn and then the idea is okay take the
rook and then capture the pawn again
yeah to try and creep in with the White
Queen may be possible although it feels
like it shouldn't work for example black
can just defend against any checks uh
Black's King as well ready to start
running you've given up two Rooks here
for white he does go for this however
prag I'm fascinated to know what was
happening after The Rook uh moved across
towards the black king that looked very
dangerous to me but Prague didn't go for
it instead he takes a pawn he's giving
up two Rooks to try and win this game
Prague
and can Magnus get greedy can he take a
second Rook that is the question
I think he can
I think Magnus can just call Price Bluff
here
maybe there's better but what can white
play okay so I just checked and
apparently the best move is actually to
capture the pawn
but uh Magnus if he's he's in a peaceful
full mood he can actually just capture
the rook and the game woofers out into a
draw
okay and that will clinch today's match
for Magnus Carlsen so if black does take
the white Rook then White's Knight can
actually Retreat to H5 and there'll be a
checking sequence that black cannot
Escape for petrol check and a draw
that's that doesn't help Prague maybe
Prague knows it as well Magnus looks
pretty calm considering he's being
attacked uh in such a brutal manner
there is a massive drama going on right
now Magnus is uh looking like he will
decide the match and be the winner of
the tour finals Arjun aragaisi has
already after three games won the match
against Liam Lair and mamad yarov has
right now decided the match against
Anish giri winning another game Muhammad
Yara of giri loses that match in three
games
and actually Wesley so could also be
about to decide the match against Duda
what a day yeah it's a completely
unexpected actually I mean I going into
this day honestly thought that we would
see tie breaks perhaps even see
Armageddon and I own I thought that the
match between Duda and so would be so
closely thought that they would perhaps
one person would win another person will
win it would go down to the wire and
I did not ever dream that all four
matches would end in three games that
for me is the shock the biggest shock
ever and of course the biggest match win
will be for Magnus Carlsen not only
winning the match against Prague but
also winning the tour finals
what do you think David will be the
result in the game do you think Magnus
will win it yes he's got he's got a load
of time on his clock he's got almost six
minutes there's not that much
calculation to be done the first move
you look at is taking White's Rook off
the board Being Greedy why not and once
you see that white has nothing more than
a Perpetual check you go for it I think
the only thing that might stop Magnus
from taking White's Rook is if he really
wants to win because he's feeling super
confident but a draw is enough in the
match right now so I think we'll see
Magnus pause for another minute or so
he'll take the rook and we'll see the
game fizzle out and it's all Psychology
today we see Duda he's a Broken Man
especially after yesterday's defeat he's
collapsed today against Wesley so Gary
feels broken as well I also the ghosts
of that game last month that manager of
destroy giri that kind of best game of
his career so he described it I think
that's played a part in their match
today and Eric I see he's on a hot
streak he won his match it's just
it's just momentum interests at the top
level it's all these two three percent
uh that you gain by being confident and
or that you lose by being despondent and
yeah right now it's
that's really showing in these one-sided
matches these results
yeah Magnus we're expecting him to take
the white Rook as you said you can just
take this Pawn back as well you're
completely fine as black
that's not too much more calculation to
be done no need to go into the depths
when Bishop takes Rook secures the draw
yeah and we'll show this one more time
maybe just on the analysis board okay he
has gone for it and we might see a
result any moment soon The Rook has
disappeared white has nothing better
than a check the black king will Retreat
another check the black king will move
and a dance between the king and Knight
this will end in a draw and let's go
back to the players we'll see a result
we'll see Magnus confirmed as the winner
of the tournament if Prague repeats
moves anything else for white and you're
just two Rooks down so I don't think you
can carry on safely will we see a
celebration for Magnus do you think
after this game
we'll see a smile yeah I have a feeling
he won't celebrate till the end of
tomorrow when the tournament is done but
now it's pretty much confirmed if white
brings his Knight back to give a check
the position will repeat itself for a
third time
and there we go it's a draw Magnus beats
Prague Magnus ground is the weather
's match he is the
the winner of the tour finals what a
tournament it's been for the world
number one he's oh most unbeaten you